hello and welcome to the webinar on
high-throughput biomedical data analysis
before I actually start up with the
webinar if you guys have anything any
questions that you come across during
the webinar please feel free to write
down it only chatbox either of the zoom
chat box or the chat box that is present
on our educational website so feel free
to put down your questions so yeah once
again welcome guys to the webinar in
this webinar we would be introducing you
to the biomedical data analysis
techniques and the approaches that you
can master and adopt to help conduct a
better research and learn about the data
science in the changing medical research
starting from the diagnosis to be
treatment selection and development of
the new therapeutic we will also like to
share with you the information and the
preview of our upcoming course that will
cover the most important aspects of the
high throughput biomedical data analysis
that would be combining the reproducible
workflows with machine learning methods
and visualization approaches for various
high-throughput biomedical data sets
this particular course is being
developed in collaboration with pine
biotech P dot IO this webinar will be
led by dr. Anand Lakshmanan
from Saint Peter IO and Ilya broad
scheme from pine biotech our teams are
working together on new training
resources for the students researchers
and the industry professionals in the
past we have conducted many courses and
workshops on the data science machine
learning and biomedical research topics
including our recent sessions at NYU
Langone Medical School University of
Kolkata in India and we do conduct
regular meetups in Washington DC where
we are helping kindig with course on
machine learning with Georgetown Medical
Center you could find all the important
links to the websites it's down in the
bottom that is t dash bar dot info CT
website that is superior io we have
learned a lot from our past experience
and we realize that it is very important
to customize our training materials so
as to suit the target audience so
as we share with you some of the topics
we plan to offer we are asking that you
help us understand your preference and
needs so for that purpose we have
designed our survey and the link to that
particular survey was already emailed to
you guys yesterday I would be copying
that link in the chat box over here
again so as to help you guys in filling
up this over now I would be handing
handing over to the presentation to dr.
Allen which confirms it Peter I oh hello
everyone my name is Anand I am the CEO
at P dot IO we are a company that does
data science and data visualization
services out of Bangalore India and
previously worked at Apple in California
and have analyzed a lot of data over the
years for multiple organizations anyway
that's about me and what I wanted to
emphasize in the next few minutes is the
power of data visualization as a tool
for human intelligence in the same way
as machine learning is a tool for
artificial intelligence now what I mean
by this is just by throwing your data
onto a chart and choosing the right kind
of geometry as in a line or a histogram
or a bar chart or a passage or a in or
an animation or a network chart by
choosing the right kind of chart there
is a large amount of low-hanging fruit
in terms of derived insightful human
intelligence that can be achieved
assuming get to the point where we take
your raw data in a way that is
meaningful to understand and then take
it to a level of visualization and then
driving maintenance now this whole thing
is it is a cycle and it's got to be
repetitive and iterative in order to
rapid prototyping and achieve your your
your results so with that context you
know you move
over to the next slide where we talk
about data science in general and of
course data science has impacted many
many industries and here I'm showing two
particular charts one is the return of
investment from ads what you see on the
left hand side where you can see that
there are four headsets and and there's
a bunch of colors and the more red the
color it means that the ad was a lot
more effective in that time slot where
the x-axis the hour of the day and the
y-axis is there is a day of the week
right so what you can see is that by a
visual like this a heatmap visual like
this you can actually figure out what
gets you the best bang for the buck
right you know the right answer if
you're seeing the market performance of
multiple cryptocurrencies and and that
helps you to analyze and predict the
trends and then maybe you think relies
on your so basically the point is that
data that is realized can help you make
better decisions because from data to
visualization visualization will bring
out surprises that you probably did not
expect and it is that surprise when put
into decision and then eventually into
action you know gets you the gives you
the results in a research environment
here's an example of a visualization
that there's particularly interesting
where you know the the heart rate is
displayed in the y-axis and then and
then of course the the time line is in
the extension how the heart rate bump
happens when a marriage proposal is
emerged so basically the - then you
visualize something you can actually
instantly find some insights just by
visualizing the pattern of data and then
associating the time line with a
particular task and then find the
differences thing we in the patterns and
a lot can be you know inferred from the
from a chart like this that's an example
of a biomechanical visualization let me
take a few more minutes to explain why
it is important to understand data
science and data visualization in the
context of biomedical field but really
it's it's applicable to several other
fields as well when I joined Apple the
director of Apple when they called me
and said that you know just four ways to
influence people French charisma
Authority and then data and of course
data is the best way among all the other
ways because it's the most sustainable
but correct way and it's it's a way that
helps us relook at the data and then be
open to changing our decisions should
the data on the ground change right so
that we always mean it's from a
data-driven perspective the second
important thing is usability now you
many of you are probably in to research
or working in a corporate world
analyzing how do you make sure that your
charts or the reports that you're
generating is reproducible what do you
need to package and and give it to your
own
you know community or your team this is
a new wave of research happening in all
producible research where you it's your
code and your raw data and your plots
together when you show your research
that way you know folks who are
decision-makers can look at just the
blocks because they probably don't have
time to look at other things and then
you know teams that for example testing
teams can look at the rod it and then
independently verify the results that
you've come to and then maybe your own
team members can look at the actual code
and then you know verify the code or
build on top of it and so on and so
forth so raw data cold and bloods
packets together in a reproducible
fashion will really accelerate the pace
of biomedical research context and
comparison is very important you you
probably have multiple groups in your in
your analysis how do you find out for
instance the mean separation or the mean
shift across groups and what are the
baselines what is the context of the
data that you are presenting all those
things can be represented or should be
represented visually in order to make
people understand your research and also
you know for yourself to convince
yourself which is really a prerequisite
before convincing others right so rapid
prototyping this is and what I mean by
rapid prototyping is some of you are
probably you know domain experts in your
area but you may not know programming as
much and some of you might be dependent
on a programmer to hand over your data
and then ask questions and then they
might come back to you with some result
results and then you will have further
questions if you are a domain expert and
a data analyst if you are able to do
visualizations yourself
you can quickly iterate from your data
to a filtered data to a transformed data
through a visualization maybe you derive
some insights and maybe that insights
will lead you to further questions that
you need to go back and reprogram and
then you know come to a better inference
from your visualization if this cycle is
completed in a much more faster manner
then your progress is going to be pretty
rapid and that is why you know we are
moving away from a an an old mindset
where you have depth of knowledge in one
area to a new mindset where you have
your depth of knowledge as in your
domain expertise and your data science
skills so a data analyst plus a domain
expert you know really makes a data
scientist and you know we would really
like you to become the best biomedical
data scientist that you can be and then
finally communication you know how are
you going to present the results of your
research and how are you going to write
a report or is it going to be a poster
or a thesis that's an important is there
a way that you can take your research
and then easily convert it into
publishable research research those
kinds of questions come to you come to
your mind and data science and data
visualization skills have a lot to offer
in that as well so finally when I talk
about programmable visualizations we are
at a stage compared to the last several
years several new tools have come up in
the domain of data science and data
visualizations where you can program
ibly create visualizations which offers
you unprecedented tools in order to go
back excuse me in order to go back and
change a particular experiment or maybe
filter and look at a different group or
summarizer
or add some extra columns of join
you know from a different data source or
compare if this is then programmatically
and then I say programmatically I am
getting to a point where you can do
programming without really being a
programmer in other words tools like our
programming and there is a set of tools
called the tidy versed methods of our
programming that we discuss in much more
detail during the course and I'll also
give you a flavor of it later on in this
in this presentation it really enables
you to become a very simplistic
programmer to the extent that
visualizations are needed and you close
the loop in order to derive insights
from your data from that perspective you
know all these you know fantastic data
science tools and context and
communication and prototyping and
reproducibility is really very very
important for it by a medical
professional so having said that let me
hand it over to Ilya Brodsky to take it
from here and he will talk about high
throughput data in the biomedical
Germany thanks very much for the
introduction to you and it's great to
see kind of the power of visualization
on and what I will be talking about is
really the high throughput data in
biomedical domain because up until now
we see the power but when we talk about
the type of data that we have it becomes
unfilial as to how to really visualize
in a powerful way
the type of data that is emerging and
exponentially increasing in the
biomedical domain so let me give it a
little bit of an overview history of
genomic data kind of how did we get here
so in 1950s the DNA double helix
structure was discovered and it took
about 40 years for that data to really
impact the way that we view health and
disease we started to understand that
you know it has a tremendous impact
across all areas of biomedical and in
fact biological research the two people
that SP
hedid that project francis collins
today's the director of nih craig venter
is the founder of human longevity that
uses integration of multi omics data to
address the challenges of aging and so
you see that those ideas have a
tremendous impact since then on what we
understand as you know the drivers of
human disease but it took another maybe
three to five years for that data to
become massively available and
affordable when Illumina started their
sequencing business and today since then
so it only took another nine to ten
years for us to have a lot of data
available so in 2015 we had the final
phase of the thousand genome project
with over a thousand genomes being
available fully sequence human genomes
and today in 2018 I think we can all
appreciate the amount of high-throughput
data that is becoming available so the
MIT Broad Institute already sequenced
over 100,000 whole genomes genomics
England over 50,000 and and of course
this is whole genome so you can imagine
that a lot more is available for other
types of data and as a result we now
understand that the disease symptoms
that we used to rely on clinical data to
measure today are really defined by the
underlying layers of what's called onyx
so we have the genomics the proteomics
transcriptomics epigenetics microbiome a
lot of data and each data set here is
huge so let's take a look at an example
data set an example data set that we'll
be using during our course and during
this short presentation is taken from a
publication in 2013 where a number of
different cell lines were taken from
breast cancers and sequenced for their
Epogen a
genetic changes or variation for their
genomic changes or DNA and for their
transcriptomics for their gene
expression and all of that data was used
to predict drug response for different
subtypes of breast cancer now to deal
with that kind of amazing quantity and
high-throughput qualities of data we
have prepared a platform that provides
easy-to-use access to multi onyx data
processing and integration and during
this little short session what I will be
showing you is how can we go from the
raw data which is short reads to a table
of expression which now starts to
resemble the type of data that you can
actually visualize so the section that
we will be looking at is transcriptomics
right here RNA seek probably law review
are familiar with RNA seek and really
what it does is it takes short reads and
transforms them into something that we
can start comparing between different
conditions so how do we process this
kind of data well you know you used to
have to know Linux and you had to you
know upload these huge data sets onto
your computer and your computer had to
be very powerful and you had to monitor
the process of data so that you transfer
it from the right folder to the right
folder and automatically build pipelines
and we decided to address that challenge
of the complexity of the processing and
prepared this intuitive interface that
simplifies the whole process to a
point-and-click interaction and as you
select each new button in each new step
you actually can learn about it as you
walk through the pipeline creation so
for example the first section you would
use some pre-processing
to reduce the amount of replicates that
don't represent the biology that are
really technical you know you then
can use very complex statistical
analysis of reeds of how they fall onto
the genome using bowtie for example and
then finally prepare a comparison
between two conditions or more
conditions but as a result of this
pipeline really what you get is a table
of expression just like this where you
have gene names as your rows and sample
names as your columns so the samples are
gonna be names of different cell lines
and of course these are breast cancer
cell lines so you would have different
names of subtypes of breast cancers and
now you can identify the differences
between numbers to understand how these
numbers can give us insight about the
differences between individual cell
lines and groups of cell lines that
could be compared now how do you deal
with this data and what's the problem
with dealing with this kind of data well
first of all it's huge you have between
20,000 and 60,000 genes for each sample
so imagine between 20,000 to 60,000 rows
in your table for however many samples
you have and how many samples do you
have well you can have tens to hundreds
of samples because we have so much data
available if you go on databases like
NCBI array Express and others you can
really see that sample that today
datasets contain multiple you know tens
to hundreds of samples and to deal with
that you need high performance computing
and and that's why our platform is on
the cloud and you don't have to upload
or download any samples you can do all
of your analysis there to prepare it for
something that you can do on your
computer
now the other challenge is that these
are very complex relationships right so
what we saw when Anand was presenting
his data you know our wife for ads or
even tracking the performance of markets
or using something like a heart rate to
visualize that data
it's intuitive we know what heart rate
is correlated to we know when our heart
beats higher or lower but with gene
expression I mean there are so many
pathways that interact in complex ways
that have different signaling or actual
functional differences between them to
know all of that it's impossible to hold
it in your head so it's not intuitive
and you really have to have additional
tools to deal with that kind of
complexity and of course it's
non-trivial to interpret that kind of
complexity right so therefore you really
have to rely on data exploration and
visualization in a programmatic way and
you have to utilize supervised and
unsupervised machine learning which is a
component of what we will show you today
and what we do in the course in a much
more expanded way so how do you go from
a table that contains all of this
complexity to a simple visual
scatterplot that can show you the
differences between for example here
luminal and other types of breast cancer
how do we do that
well just in the same way we can use the
platform and upload and have this huge
data set already on the system so that
we don't have to rely on our personal
computers and then we just use this
simple chart to create a principal
component analysis and this is an
example here on the right that you can
see rotating a number of dots in a
multi-dimensional space reduced here to
three dimensions but in reality it's
multi-dimensional and you can see how
turning this scatter of dots can
actually help you see that some angles
show differences between different
groups much better than others and
that's what PCA does PCA actually will
take the table and rotate it in such a
way that we can separate it into a
two-dimensional space so to flatten it
and and make it much more simple so
before we go on I am just going to
quickly demonstrate how to do
so what I have here is the platform the
tion for platform and you can see that
we had the raw data processing right
here and what I will do is go under
unsupervised analysis and you can see
this pipeline that I just showed and I'm
just going to upload a file so I have
the cell lines expression data right
here in fact I'm going to use the marked
where I have the marking of the
different subgroups continue I press
start and as you can see every time I
click I can learn about what this
procedure does so here you can see that
the principal component analysis is a
statistical procedure that uses an
orthogonal transformation to convert a
set of observations or possibly
correlated that variables into instead
of values of linearly uncorrelated
they're they're both called principal
components okay so I changed the
dimensionality and I can then visualize
it in a much more simple way so I click
on end
save this pca gene expression example
and during the course by the way each
one of you will have access to the
platform for the duration of the course
and now I've run this analysis now I'm
not going to wait for it to finish
because I already have prepared pipeline
from before they download pipeline
output and what I get is a PDF so I'm
just going to download this PDF
and I can take a look at the sample
separated between luminal normal like
and then basal and cloud and lung now I
have some insight into the data some
basic idea of what the data contains and
what I will do is I will actually hand
it over back to an event to talk about
how do you improve this visualization to
make it much more informative for
downstream analysis so now let's go to
hands-on on on data visualization right
so for this hands on data visualization
part I'm going to go to a platform
called the our Studio IDE where the
screen that you are seeing here is on
the left hand side is it's a set of
programming will actually go into much
more detail in the programming in the
actual course but what I want to point
out here is how do you go from the
output of the pipeline and run this
principal component analysis and take
the results and you see this this
percentage greater than percentage that
actually means the pipe which basically
means you take whatever is there on the
left hand side and pass it on to the
right hand side and think of it like a
stage by stage cascade and then get to a
plot and you see a plot that's something
like this what you see in in this screen
is how so let me first explain the
different colors the different colors
represent the different groups of basil
luminal normal light so on and so forth
and each of these each of these data
points comes from the from the sample
and and you see these lines those at the
end of the lines the actual genes
indicated the label is given here so for
example let's say we take this
particular gene E and s G 0 0 0 0 0 160
180 we can see that in this particular
direction
this gene is responsible for the maximum
separation of this group and this group
right
this group is de luminary versus you
know the other group is normal like for
example so what you see in front is a a
visual way of representing the cluster
of data points colored in specific ways
that enable you to see the differences
between groups and not only that to be
able to identify that particular gene
which is responsible for the most
separation between the groups and that
for you know we can actually identify
which gene is an important player in
this on top of it you can actually this
is an interactive visualization alright
so as you let me clear the annotation
and then then show you that you can for
example as you hover over each data
points you can actually see the variable
values and in the routes and if you are
particularly interested in in let's say
one one of these you can actually zoom
in into a lot more detail because when
you zoom in you are going to get like
individual level data and you can
programmable make sure that you can
display whatever you want in the tooltip
and that's for you know it helps speed
up you excuse me it helps speed up your
own research process but also it's
important to zoom ouch and then and then
see the overall picture because overall
picture gives you a much better insight
in ways that zooming in does not give
you as a general principle of data
visualization this ability to zoom in
and zoom out is very critical when it
comes to research and I would recommend
that you keep Google Maps or active maps
in mind we're in for example if you're
using the maps you know it is a pretty
complicated map if it's a ton of
information roads and satellite data and
track
in buildings and whatnot but yet you
know it gives you information about
where you are and where you wanna go and
to our three paths in front of you right
so you can zoom out and then figure out
the overall strategy and then you can
zoom in and then take the next step as
in you know turn right so on so in other
words you know if you're if we are able
to have that analogy in mind and then
come up with an overall picture by
zooming out and then also zooming in to
do individual analysis of each data
point right so that's what this this
visual represents so now let me go back
to the presentation so I guess you know
the that's what I wanted to say and you
can go and I think I'll pass it on to a
layer two to explain this chart in the
context of raw data what you're seeing
here on the left hand side is the actual
principal component analysis and now
that we know that this particular gene
is important we can go back to the raw
data which is shown on the right hand
side and and earlier can explain what we
should look for in the raw data given
the new insight that we got from the
principal component analysis over to
thank you on so yes as you can see
visualization helps me identify some
trend in the data and like we said
before it on trivial that this gene for
example has some role in separation
between luminal and the other types now
the best difference that this principal
component and shows us is indeed between
luminal and basil or luminol and normal
like but we know from biology that basil
and normal light are fairly similar so
you can see this on the PCA they're
closer together and in fact on the right
side if you take a look at the level of
expression you can see that the majority
of the luminal are upregulated or highly
expressed and the ones on the right side
are all low expressed and so you can see
how this difference you know if you
imagine having a table of thousands of
row has thousands of rows how do you
find this one gene well that's
machine learning really comes in to help
you extract these things and then help
me visualize and explore your data so
that you can interact with it so now you
can see that this is the team and these
are the two groups that we see the
biggest difference and these are
actually two different subtypes that we
can interpret the biological meaning of
this gene expression now all of this was
the little preview and an explanation of
what the types of things that we will do
during our course so the course that we
are about to launch as a joint course
between Sir Pio and and Pine biotech is
to take this high-throughput data
genomics transcriptomics epigenomics
data and address the challenges of
high-throughput biomedical data how to
process how to use machine learning how
to use visualization and really give you
hands-on experience that will combine
some user-friendly tools like I showed
you all in the platform and some
programming simple programming that you
can incorporate into your workflow so
that your practical skills in are and
using user-friendly tools give you
ability to visualize and gain director
insights and hopefully make your
research more reproducible
also navigate the data so that your
research is data-driven and bottom line
more impactful when you incorporate
these kinds of skills into your workflow
really the result is that you will
understand the methods you will
understand the high throughput
challenges and biomedical data
processing you will understand how to
approach analysis and how to visualize
your results and inside the course
actually throughout the course we will
use several different projects that are
relevant to clinical applications I mean
how do you use genomic data in the
clinic
you know in research how do you
understand the basic biology behind
these genes and and behind these samples
that we have and and even pharmaceutical
topics how do you use gene expression
data to design new therapeutics to
identify new targets how do you use it
to reposition drugs and and repurpose
different drugs you will be able to
prepare and plan your own analysis as
Anand was saying you will be able to
think and convince with data and not
just with words and and you know
imagination and finally you'll be able
to really incorporate all of this into
your own portfolio and your resume so
you will be able to stand out from the
crowd when you go and apply for your
position or when you want to advance
your own career in your current position
you can claim having more skills and
more capabilities and I want to touch on
one other point that you know maybe is
you know hasn't been highlighted it's
important to understand that today's
publications are changing from printed
compilations of results into something
that somebody else can take and and
follow your steps and validate that
indeed what you're saying is true but
also explore other things and you know
I'm talking about others but I want to
talk about you your research your
publications your work you want to be
able to improve your work by comparing
it to what other people did and
therefore you need to understand their
methods by understanding what their data
says therefore you have to be able to
rapidly go through other people's data
and intuitively understand what it means
and where are their correct assumptions
and incorrect assumptions and then you
want to actually publish more impactful
things even without the need to generate
a lot of your own data because of course
so much data is available today
so these are some of the topics that we
will be covering I don't I don't know if
you want to add anything to these points
that I just need yes so I want to add a
couple more things one of the very
important takeaways from this course
that you will get is a transferable
skill that can be applied throughout
your career whether or not you stick to
the biomedical field later on you know
people switch carriers all the time and
if you you know get data analysis and
visualization skills pretty much there
is no field today that does not analyze
data and feels like finance for example
I have taken this algorithmic processing
of financial data to a to a completely
different level and they're like banking
on it in turn in order to do investments
and analyze portfolios on and so forth
right several other tools are being
invented across domains but the ability
to visualize step by step and use
visualization as a diagnostic tool for
your data quality problems for your data
wrangling and transformation issues your
machine learning visualization of
machine learning in explanation of your
particular procedure that transcends the
biomedical field so while you can do a
better research in terms of your your
own biomedical data that you are
following what you're learning is
something that will follow you
throughout your your life is one point
that I wanted to infer the second thing
is both silky and fine
you know we are dedicated to education
and and we will take we will go the
extra mile in terms of you know
connecting with you to make sure that
you understand the problem that you have
in front of you from the context of
either domain expertise in which case
Alea will help out or in if it comes to
visualization of your pipeline results
and
learning simple our programming for
visualizations in which case soon people
will come and help you
so that's what I wanted to add to this
and oh do you Illya okay yeah I think
those are great points and at this point
we do have a little bit of time for
questions
if you have any questions related to the
examples that we show owed or related to
the upcoming course please go ahead you
can either write them in chat or you can
unmute yourself and speak up I think
there are some questions also that
perhaps Sahil can cycle if you find any
questions it's a return if you can you
know speak out those questions you know
one of us can take those questions if
there is a yeah okay
I see here will the course focus on what
various ml algorithms we can develop or
just follow the existing pipelines
available so Ruthie thank you for your
question
I think so he'll already said that you
know we will touch on both aspects in
reality what you see today and this is
actually a very interesting topic that
machine learning started emerging as a
fairly rapidly increasing topic in
biomedical research starting about the
same time that genomic data started
becoming more and more available and you
know it's obvious why you have explosion
of data and change of data you can't
rely on simple and intuitive
interpretation so you referred to other
tools that do it automatically and
surprisingly in 2015 that trend started
changing for several reasons one reason
is that diversification of machine
learning tools you start having deep
learning you start having neural
networks you start having classification
the new methods that started appearing
classification unsupervised machine
learning is actually called data mining
a lot of times so you really have this
kind of you know if you think of a tree
branching out of machine learning which
a lot of times people referred to you
know things like PCA like we show today
as your standard machine learning tools
into much much more variety and today
when we talk about developing your own
machine learning methods really what we
mean is how to effectively combine these
different methods and modify them so
that we can do feature engineering so
that we can do pipelines of machine
learning methods so that you can arrive
more impactful results and that is well
that will be the focus of our course we
will not actually touch on you know
algorithmic development but we will
touch on how to optimize and how to
appropriately select the right methods
for the analysis goal we will touch on
feature selection and feature
engineering to a level that you can
apply it to biomedical data and of
course we will do a lot more on the data
visualization side so that the results
of machine learning that often times you
know just kind of pop up and you know
become like a black box you don't know
why you arrived at this conclusion so
that it's more clear you can actually go
back and understand what is the reason
why these things were selected let me
add so yeah go ahead sorry let me add
one more thing to this so for the input
of your machine learning models the
quality of data is critical and for this
particular in this platform here using
existing data and if it's already
cleaned up that's one thing but if you
have other datasets and if you want to
get a handle on how to clean up the data
and how to use data visualization as a
diagnostic tool to understand data
quality problems for example using GM
density and then finding out whether
your data has you know extreme outliers
and if so do they make sense
understanding the bounds of the raw data
to evaluate the quality of the raw data
as the input feed for your machine
learning models become crucial in order
to have increased the confidence of the
output of your machine learning models
that makes sense so we you know we'll
talk about data visualization in the
class to be able to clean up the data
and then have a much more higher quality
input stream of data for your ml models
Thank You Anandi and here's another
question from Deborah um and I want to
address that as well so she's saying I
have no prior experience of
next-generation sequencing
though I have worked on capillary
sequencing and hence how this course is
going to help me as I am a hardcore
molecular biologist working in rnd of a
company so you know I'm going to address
it for my perspective which is more on
the data side and less on the wet lab
side but I do want to say that today
biology is obviously very data-driven
I mean if you literally pick up any
publication you will have a method
section and the majority of them will
use you know some level of statistical
analysis obviously and a lot of them
will incorporate machine learning a lot
of them will refer to data a lot of them
will give access to the data and I think
that you know a lot of that is driving
more effective R&D and I can give you a
practical example so practical example
we are working with a lab that is
sequencing a lot of data from infectious
diseases as they are being as a certain
therapeutic is being tested on mice and
you have a lot of variables
obviously the mice get sick and then you
know their sacrifice their die and you
have to understand well you know how do
I measure the effectiveness of this
therapeutic that I'm developing on this
specific disease and you have a lot of
variables to consider right the
individuality of the mouse the different
proportions you know size etcetera
health of the mouse the different time
points when you infect the mouse the
different amounts of the this compound
that you're testing you know the place
where you inject and and these are just
on the surface right so these are on the
surface but deeper down you have so much
variation that is on the Onix level that
the question becomes well how do you may
this process more efficient than just
trying something because you think it
should work intuitively and the answer
to that is that you have to refer to the
data to drive your next experiments you
have to have access to the data you have
to be able to integrate that data on
some level and you have to really
identify where a signal and where is
noise and how do you use that signal to
plan your next steps and that's a little
bit of what we will try and focus in
this course we will take several
examples that incorporate this kind of
data to arrive at some conclusions that
are relevant to you know R&D in in
biotech companies that are relevant to
clinical Diagnostics that are relevant
to understanding of the basic biology on
some level we're not going to do a
molecular biology course on you know
full fledged
interpretation of results but we will
utilize some tools you know like
annotation and pathway annotation etc so
that you can at least have you know an
ability to move in that direction and
you know maybe this is relevant to what
many is asking what data sets or types
of biomedical problems we'll be
addressing in the course so I've
referenced one example the one example
that we used was essentially a
collection of cell lines different
breast cancer cell lines that we have
multi omics data available for and those
include genomic data and epigenetic data
like chip seek and gene expression data
which includes gene expression Aiza form
expression RNA editing etc and yes I
would say that you know a lot of this is
going to be focused on high-throughput
biomedical data which will be onyx and
that's not just you know transcriptomics
but but it will incorporate you know NGS
and how it's relevant to phenotypes
right so the phenotypes are going to be
in this case in the case of the project
that we looked at is actually data from
screening so IG 50 inhibition of cell
proliferation and how do you find the
correlation between those data and the
signal from almonds and how can you
combine the two to predict the
effectiveness of specific compounds that
were tested on those so on so that's
gonna be one example the second example
that we will use is the data set from a
toxicology data set so basically there
are many compounds some of them are
known to be toxic some of them are known
to be non-toxic right therefore more
useful for designing different
therapeutic compounds and so the
question is how can we differentiate
between the two how can we identify
early on some indication of toxicity
based on descriptors of these molecules
so no next-generation sequencing data
but the data is going to be biochemical
so it's going to be using the physical
chemical properties of these molecules
and we will learn how to use machine
learning tools to differentiate between
the two and to understand what is the
relationship between the physical
chemical properties and the final effect
of that molecule okay another question
here from Benedict which machine
learning algorithms that applied most in
biomedical data again I think it's I can
actually share with you a few my shoot
me an email a very nice publication that
did analysis of recent biomedical
publications and the utilization of
different types of algorithms so we have
you know three or four different
categories of machine learn right so for
example you can separate them into
supervised and unsupervised right so
unsupervised would be things like
clustering and dimensionality reduction
and supervised will be classification
network analysis etc so what is the
difference between the two well the
difference is primarily you would use
one to mine your data you're looking for
trends in the data and the other one
will be more on okay how do I use a
trained data set to predict some quality
of a new data set that I've generated
and so in biomedical field you can also
start thinking about the types of
problems in biomedical research could be
separated into two categories like that
sometimes you want to you know explore
the data and sometimes you actually want
to use some results of an analysis to
help you you know for example apply
those classifications to a new data set
so to answer your question though more
directly PCA has been used since you
know the beginning of genomic sequencing
extensively and in a growing way up
until 2015 more recently people started
using t-sne or tease me for
dimensionality reduction for example and
primarily that's because of single cell
sequencing where it's become much more
popular so you know those are two
examples of very useful machine learning
methods that have been widely popular
and used and not only that also used for
to support different classifications on
this one different clustering techniques
etc so I don't think there's a list of
very you know most most there what did
you call it most they're applied most
but we will touch on the different
categories and the different types and
of course see what is they're used so
that you can appropriately either use
them as is or modify them in a pipeline
or modify the data that
feed into those algorithms like Annan
said by filtering by feature engineering
by preparing the data and making sure
that the data quality because bottom
line is garbage in garbage out right if
you don't feed the algorithm with good
data it doesn't help you if the
algorithm is good or not okay
I don't know Annan do you want to add
anything to these questions
okay well so again it would be great
that if you have any further questions
you can actually email us directly you
can also write those questions in the
survey to register for the course so
let's just go on to the next slide in
the in the course itself we will publish
the full curriculum of the course based
on your survey replies so if you want us
to consider what you think is the most
interesting topic I mean we are not
limited to the things that we discussed
here these are just some examples and
we're still in the planning process of
the course itself and of course you are
welcome to help guide us so that we so
that we can more appropriately address
your needs okay final question should we
be trained on how to arrange reads
generated from NGOs followed by its
announcement interpretation so Debra we
will actually practice that will not go
into the algorithmic or statistical
detail but what I showed in the
beginning is you that can be a very
intuitive and simple process and we will
actually cover a lot of that in our
course so you know if you don't know a
lot about processing of next-generation
sequencing data we will do that for you
I mean we will train you how to do it
and you'll be able to practice on
several data sets so you get a better
idea of what combinations of methods
work best and what are the outputs what
are the inputs etc and again we have
other courses available on our platform
on edu dot T - bio info that you can
actually take full courses on NGS on
transcriptomics on genomics on
metagenomics and you can you know those
are free of charge you can take those
and try those out if you want
I do want to mention you know there were
some questions about machine learning we
do have a course that's available it is
a paid course because it is being done
for Georgetown Medical Center jointly
with them but if you're interested in
machine learning for a next-generation
sequencing for high throughput data go
ahead and take a look on edu dot t-- -
bio that info we do have a full course
on machine learning it is right now
being recorded and put out so you can
definitely enroll because the first
lessons are already available but the
full course will be completed by the end
of October and so this is a perfect time
to join so just as a final note we do
have more resources available on our
site T - bio info and syrupy dot I al
also does training workshops now on
visualization in scripting in R and you
should definitely check out their
websites sir P dot 0 and we will be able
to either enroll you in this course that
we are jointly developing but you will
definitely benefit from looking out at
the existing resources and joining one
of the separate workshops that we are
conducting and on do you want to add
anything to this so I just want to add
one quick thing that from CIPA dot IO
perspective the vision of the company is
to have data science and data
visualization at the core and then
identify specific domain areas and
collaborate with folks in different
areas and come up with courses so to
that extent you know we have the course
called data science using our that we
that we developed internally as as an
independent program and definitely check
it out at safety dot io / courses where
it will be a little bit more programming
intensive but still geared towards
domain experts without having the need
to go through like complicated
programming constructs and still be able
to
import Randall visualize transform
summarize and visualize and model and
get results out of your data so that's a
full course by itself and then we had
other courses like data science for
equity market analysis if you're a
finance person and then of course with
this giant course with find by you that
we are really excited to to tell you
about and if you have any specific needs
we can also customize certain courses to
in groups of you or individuals or
corporates of universities especially
this new tie diverse methods of pipeline
programming and are is something that we
are really passionate about it's silky
and more than happy to engage with your
individual needs yeah I think it was
great to you know do this together and
hopefully we will send out an email
update about the other plans that we
have so please stay in touch by filling
out the survey if you have any issues
with the survey you will also have our
contact information and of course we
already have your emails so look out for
that update from our side as well and
again happy to you know get to know some
of you and answer some of these
questions so thanks very much